Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous le savez, le Festival de Cannes commence dans 2 jours,
pour l'occasion, on va vous parler de films.
Alors, pas les plus grands, les plus longs ou les plus chers, non, les films maudits.
Ceux dont le tournage a été le plus galère.
Apocalypse Now, L'Exorciste et Don Quichotte,
des films où tu vas voir, rien ne s'est passé comme prévu.
Les coulisses du cinéma, c'est ton truc.
Et on va commencer par un tournage complètement fou,
celui d'Apocalypse Now.
Ça commence.
Un tournage fou,
c'est vraiment le mot.
Nous sommes en 1975.
À cette époque, Coppola a le vent en poupe,
il est le réalisateur du "Parrain 1" et 2, deux gros cartons planétaires.
À Hollywood, c'est le roi du pétrole
mais le nouveau film qu'il prépare n'a rien à voir avec les précédents.
C'est une adaptation du roman "Au cœur des ténèbres" de Joseph Conrad,
à ceci près que l'intrigue est transposée
au cœur de la guerre du Vietnam dans les années 60.
Le pitch du film est le suivant,
c'est l'histoire du capitaine Willard,
chargé par les services secrets américains
de remonter un fleuve jusqu'à la jungle cambodgienne pour retrouver et tuer
le colonel américain Kurtz, qui serait devenu fou.
Coppola s'inspire d'un slogan hippie "Nirvana Now"
pour baptiser son film "Apocalypse Now".
Et, pour ce tournage, il négocie un très gros budget.
16 millionsde dollars, ce qui lui permet de tourner en décor réel
aux Philippines, les paysages ressemblent beaucoup à ceux du Vietnam.
Pour le rôle de Kurtz, le réalisateur choisit de faire appel
à l'une des plus grandes stars du cinéma mondial : Marlon Brando.
Coppola le connaît bien,
ils ont travaillé ensemble sur Le Parrain.
Pour le rôle principal, celui de Willard, c'est plus compliqué.
Il a pensé à Steve McQueen, Robert De Niro, Robert Redford, Jack Nicholson,
mais tous refusent de participer au film.
Ça commence très mal.
Finalement, Coppola mise sur un acteur moins connu, Harvey Keitel.
Après 3 semaines de tournage, le réalisateur décide de jeter
un œil sur les rushs.
Et ça donne quoi ?
C'est la cata,
Keitel n'est pas à la hauteur.
Coppola décide de le virer et jette tout ce qu'il vient de tourner à la poubelle.
Allez, on ne se démonte pas.
Coppola propose le rôle à un autre acteur, Martin Sheen, le père de Charlie Sheen.
Cette fois, c'est la bonne.
Le tournage peut reprendre, mais le 19 mai 1976, deuxième douche froide.
C'est le cas de le dire,
un typhon s'abat sur l'archipel des Philippines
et détruit tout sur son passage :
les décors, le matériel ; tout est noyé sous la boue.
Le réalisateur frôle la faillite.
D'après l'équipe de tournage,
il est devenu fou, complètement parano.
Heureusement, il parvient à se reprendre.
On reconstruit les décors en quelques semaines
et le tournage reprend une nouvelle fois.
Mais lorsque Brando débarque sur le plateau,
le metteur en scène n'en croit pas ses yeux,
l'acteur a pris 40 kilos.
Pire encore, Coppola affirme que Brando n'a pas préparé son rôle en amont.
On se calme, on respire,
à chaque problème sa solution.
Brando s'enferme une semaine pour travailler son personnage.
Ok, il apprend son texte, mais pour son poids ?
Alors, pour masquer son embonpoint, on décide de le filmer en gros plan
et dans la pénombre.
Ce qui au final va donner un vrai style au film.
Bon, là, on se dit que les ennuis
sont terminés.
Eh bien, pas si vite.
Coppola n'est pas encore au bout de ses peines.
Le 1ᵉʳ mars 1977, il doit faire face à une nouvelle catastrophe.
Martin Sheen, son acteur principal, qui fait son jogging
comme tous les matins, s'effondre.
Attaque cardiaque.
S'il meurt, le film est foutu.
Il faut l'hospitaliser en urgence à Manille, la capitale des Philippines.
Un mois plus tard, ouf !
Martin Sheen, rétabli, est de retour sur le plateau
et le 21 mai 1977, clap de fin,
le film est dans la boîte.
Le travail de post-production peut enfin commencer.
Oui mais pour la production le film est un naufrage,
le tournage devait durer 6 semaines,
Jamy, et au final, il s'est étalé sur 16 mois.
En prime, il explose le budget.
Il coûte 31 millionsde dollars au lieu des 16 prévus, à l'origine.
On pourrait croire que cette catastrophe s'arrête là,
pas du tout, le montage s'éternise lui aussi pendant 2 ans.
Si bien qu'en 1979, lorsque le film est sélectionné
pour le Festival de Cannes, il n'est pas terminé.
C'est donc une œuvre inachevée
qui est présentée en compétition officielle,
une première.
Mais, surprise, il reçoit la Palme d'or à égalité
avec un autre film,
"Le Tambour" de Volker Schlöndorff.
Et, il faut attendre 2019, soit 40 ans après la première projection,
pour que le réalisateur soit enfin satisfait de son montage
avec sa version définitive : "Apocalypse Now Final Cut".
Ce chef d'œuvre n'est pas le premier à avoir connu un tournage mouvementé.
5 ans avant le tournage de L'Exorciste,
l'histoire d'une petite fille possédée par le diable,
a également marqué l'Histoire du cinéma.
Ce film de William Friedkin a littéralement traumatisé les acteurs.
Il serait même à l'origine du décès de plusieurs personnes.
L'Exorciste,
un enfer pour les acteurs.
Le récit des coulisses fait froid dans le dos,
presque autant que le film lui-même.
Première difficulté pour William Friedkin, trouver des comédiens
qui n'ont pas peur de flirter avec Satan pendant quelques mois.
Pas simple.
Jane Fonda, pressentie pour jouer la mère de la petite fille,
est horrifiée par le scénario,
elle refuse.
Audrey Hepburn hésite un peu mais elle finit, aussi, par décliner.
Finalement, c'est une actrice moins connue,
Ellen Burstyn, qui accepte à condition
que son personnage ne prononce pas la phrase "Je crois au diable".
Elle ne sait pas encore ce qui l'attend.
Enfin, pour jouer le rôle de la petite fille possédée,
le réalisateur rencontre près de 500 actrices.
Finalement, il choisit Linda Blair, une inconnue.
Et là encore, le tournage commence mal.
Il se passe des choses étranges sur ce plateau,
par exemple, un incendie inexpliqué qui retarde le travail de 6 semaines.
Et puis, il y a Jason Miller, l'acteur qui joue le prêtre,
il apprend que son fils de 5 ans a été percuté par une moto
et qu'il est hospitalisé dans un état très grave.
Miller s'écarte quelque temps du tournage
et quand il revient, il va mal.
Il lui arrive de s'effondrer sur le plateau en plein tournage.
Mais à en croire l'équipe, le réalisateur William Friedkin n'a aucune pitié
au contraire, il décide d'utiliser ses moments de détresse
pour rendre les scènes encore plus vrai.
Il n'hésite pas non plus à gifler violemment
un de ses comédiens,
juste avant de crier "Action !",
pour que l'éclat de ses larmes soit plus convaincant.
Le comportement tyrannique du réalisateur va plus loin, encore.
Lors d'une scène clé où la mère de la petite est projetée en arrière contre un mur
par le démon, le système de catapulte prévu à cet effet se dérègle.
Comme par hasard.
Et, Ellen Burstyn est effectivement catapultée,
mais beaucoup plus violemment que prévu.
Est-ce un coup du diable ou de Friedkin lui-même ?
Toujours est-il, que l'actrice se blesse
grièvement le dos et se casse le coccyx.
Elle hurle de douleur mais le réalisateur est ravi,
il garde le cri et juge la scène absolument parfaite.
Il n'épargne pas non plus
la jeune Linda Blair, âgée de seulement 14 ans, à l'époque du tournage.
D'après certains récits, Friedkin
tient à ce que de réelles vapeurs glaciales sortent de la bouche de la jeune fille,
pour un effet plus satanique.
Alors, il fait littéralement congeler le plateau
en maintenant la température en-dessous de 0 degré
avec un système d'air conditionné.
Friedkin est accusé de violence, mais il assume.
Et, ce n'est pas tout.
Plusieurs décès surviennent étrangement dans l'entourage du film.
L'un des acteurs, Jack McGowan, meurt
quelques jours après la sortie du film.
Le grand-père de Linda Blair fait aussi partie de ce décompte macabre,
de même qu'un veilleur de nuit et même un expert des effets spéciaux.
À priori, ces décès liés à la vieillesse, n'ont rien à voir avec le film
mais c'est du pain béni pour William Friedkin.
Eh oui, il comprend vite
que le récit des coulisses de son film fait fureur auprès des journalistes
alors, il en rajoute.
Il affirme que Linda Blair, qui est doublée pour avoir
une voix démoniaque, n'a en fait pas été doublée.
D'après lui, elle serait devenue folle pendant le tournage.
Il raconte aussi qu'au montage,
des images subliminales
seraient apparues sur la bobine.
D'autres récits affirment même qu'un véritable tueur en série était présent
parmi les seconds rôles.
Le diable fait recette,
à sa sortie, L'Exorciste connaît un succès fulgurant.
C'est aujourd'hui, l'un des films les plus vus de l'histoire du cinéma.
Et en 2021, William Friedkin sort un documentaire intitulé
"L'Exorciste selon William Friedkin" où il revient en détail sur ce making-off infernal.
À la troisième place de cet étonnant podium,
on trouve un autre cinéaste qui a tenté le diable
pour aller au bout de son film, Terry Gilliam.
En 1998, il se lance dans l'adaptation
de "Don Quichotte" de Cervantes.
Et vous allez le voir, lui aussi va devoir faire face à des vents contraires.
Lorsque Terry Gilliam se lance dans l'aventure,
ça fait plus de 10 ans qu'il a ce projet en tête.
Don Quichotte, c'est l'histoire d'un homme fou de littérature de chevalerie
qui va se mettre en tête  de traverser l'Espagne pour sauver le monde,
en se battant contre des moulins à vent.
Pour son film, Gilliam prend quelques libertés avec le roman.
Il décide de mélanger 2 époques, hier et aujourd'hui,
et de raconter l'histoire de Toby,
un jeune publicitaire qui tourne un spot en Espagne
avec les personnages de Cervantes.
D'un coup, Toby se retrouve projeté 4 siècles en arrière
et fait la connaissance du fameux Don Quichotte.
Pour son casting, Terry Gilliam a convaincu Johnny Depp
de jouer Toby, le publicitaire.
Vanessa Paradis décroche le premier rôle féminin.
Pour jouer Don Quichotte, le réalisateur tente un choix, pour le moins
inattendu, celui de Jean Rochefort.
L'acteur français, âgé de 68 ans, est un passionné d'équitation
et un très bon cavalier.
Ce rôle est une aubaine pour lui
car de nombreuses scènes se déroulent à cheval.
Au départ, ce tournage se présente donc sous les meilleurs auspices
sauf que côté budget, c'est plus compliqué, Jamy.
Le réalisateur évalue le coût de son film à 60 millionsde dollars
et les studios américains,
seuls capables d'une telle dépense,
ne le suivent pas.
Un film tiré d'un roman espagnol du XVIIᵉ siècle
ne peut intéresser que des studios européens.
Le réalisateur parvient malgré tout à réunir l'argent.
Mais à peine le tournage commencé,
il apprend que le producteur allemand fait marche arrière.
Le budget, déjà serré, est divisé par 2
et, ça se sent.
Les accessoires pour les costumes sont de mauvaise qualité,
le matériel arrive en retard, comme les décors.
Rien ne va.
Malgré tout, Gilliam garde la foi,
il mise tout sur son trio d'acteurs gagnant.
Mais là encore, rien ne va se passer comme prévu.
Pour tourner les premières scènes à cheval avec Jean Rochefort,
le metteur en scène a choisi une réserve naturelle, près de Madrid.
Sauf qu'une fois sur place,
il découvre que l'endroit est à 2 pas d'une base aérienne.
Des hélicoptères survolent en permanence le lieu de tournage,
les techniciens s'arrachent les cheveux,
le bruit empêche la prise de son.
Et le lendemain, c'est un torrent de grêle qui emporte
tout le matériel sur son passage.
Dans la région, les habitants n'ont jamais vu ça.
Après 5 jours de pluie, le soleil réapparaît
et le tournage peut reprendre.
Mais le pire reste à venir.
Jean Rochefort ne dit rien, mais son visage se crispe
et son corps se raidit quand il grimpe sur son cheval.
Il n'a pas osé en parler à Terry Gilliam,
mais il souffre d'une hernie discale, horriblement douloureux.
Il doit rentrer en France pour consulter son médecin.
Coupé, Rochefort ne reviendra jamais.
L'état de son dos ne lui permet plus de monter à cheval.
Le tournage est annulé.
Pour Gilliam, c'est un échec monumental,
il racontera l'histoire de ce rêve avorté
dans un documentaire intitulé "Lost in la Mancha",
je vous le conseille.
Mais il ne renonce pas pour autant à son film.
Contre toute attente, en 2009, il annonce la reprise de cette superproduction
avec un casting flamboyant : Robert Duvall et Ewan McGregor.
Mais la malchance frappe encore,
les financiers le lâchent une nouvelle fois.
En 2014, rebelote.
Gilliam fait cette fois appel à John Hurt et Jack O'Connell.
Il obtient les financements,
on y est presque, mais John Hurt découvre qu'il est atteint
d'un cancer juste avant le tournage.
Patatra !
Finalement en 2017,
alors que ce film est déjà culte, sans exister,
Terry Gilliam surprend le monde entier.
Cette fois, c'est du lourd,
Jonathan Pryce est Don Quichotte,
Adam Driver incarne Toby.
Le film est prêt à sortir, sauf qu'au dernier moment,
un conflit sur les droits avec son producteur Paolo Branco
menace encore la diffusion du film.
Le réalisateur, à bout de nerfs, remporte
malgré tout cette bataille juridique.
et le 19 mai 2018,
le Festival de Cannes projette enfin "L'homme qui tua Don Quichotte".
Et, je laisse le mot de la fin à Lauren.
Terry Gilliam a gagné sa bataille contre les moulins à vent.
Morale de l'histoire, les cinéastes sont les Don Quichotte des temps modernes.
Merci Lauren.
Je vous l'avais bien dit, que ces films étaient maudits.
Alors des histoires comme celles-ci, on en a plein nos tiroirs.
Pas vrai ?
Alors si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à la liker,
à laisser des commentaires et à vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Allez, à dimanche prochain.
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.